nuevamente atacada Rusia lanzó drones de
fabricación iraní desde el mar de asoff
que provocaron daños en zonas
residenciales y en dos edificios
gubernamentales de la capital ucraniana
hay seis ventanas que ya no están cuatro
ventanas en el dormitorio y dos en la
cocina los niños estaban en el
dormitorio Qué bueno que no voló el
vidrio según la versión de kiev el
sistema de defensa aéreo ucraniano logró
derribar la mayoría de los drones por lo
que los ataques rusos no causaron
víctimas
los terroristas comenzaron la mañana con
13 drones chajet según información
preliminar los tres se fueron derribados
por nuestro sistema de defensa aérea
bien hecho estoy orgulloso
estos nuevos ataques se producen a
tortas que comience el invierno en
Ucrania en medio de las calles Nevadas
esta residente cuestiona la guerra
se acerca el invierno Cómo puede
sobrevivir la gente señor que quieren de
nosotros nos dejaran vivir a los
ucranianos una nación com
recientes ataques rusos han afectado
gran parte de la infraestructura
eléctrica y Ucrania ha denunciado que
Rusia utilizará el invierno como un arma
de guerra